the winner of this season's golden mask
is
night angel
oh after weeks and weeks of competition
the mass singer finally crowned its
season three winner
in the night angel welcome back to
unmasking the mass singer here again in
quarantine i'm deidre behar
and i'm charlie o'keefe and we are both
very excited i think i am a little
more excited because my angel was my
favorite
and let's take a look at who is now the
winner underneath that mask
it is for a long time i like really stop
singing by myself and i just really
appreciate you guys for
helping me build my confidence back up
the queen
has her crown i have never been more
thankful
i am so happy to see candy unmasked
finally
after weeks and weeks of guessing her
and i'm very very excited that the
judges finally got her in their final
guesses
yeah i mean look i i have to give credit
where it's due jenny mccarthy
was on to the whole candy burris theme
and i have to say
this is the first time we've had a woman
take
the masked singer trophy of course we
had t-pain season one wayne brady season
two like give it up for candy
a an entrepreneur a woman who is so
gifted vocally
and i loved what she said how you know
so many people try to knock you down and
they try to make you think that you're
not as good as you
you hope that you are and this show
renewed that confidence and i know you
and i charlie have said it time and time
again but candy this is a formal ask
for more new music oh completely and
just a reminder if
you didn't see all her incredible
performances she's saying million
reasons by lady gaga she did rise up by
andre day
she did last dance by donna summer how
to love lil wayne like
it was unstoppable and tonight the
rivers were deep the mountains were high
and it was an unstoppable
incredible performance take a look again
[Music]
and i have to say it i mean obviously it
was deserving of the win but
i i'm pretty confident in saying that i
think candy had the best performance
tonight
you know i was watching it and it was
reminding me of beyonce's coachella set
like the boots and the the glitter and
the gold
vibes and it just it just reminds you in
case you forgot that candy burris is a
force she's an incredible performer and
such a gifted vocalist
job well done queen candy we have loved
watching you all season
and deidra i know he is your favorite
contestant this season
the turtle who we finally saw unmasked
if you missed it
take a look
i know this this is an experience i'll
never forget truly
well unfortunately unlike the tortoise
and the hare
slow and steady did not win this race
for my beloved turtle you know i've been
pulling for him
so deeply since literally week one when
he graced us with
unbelievable vocals but jessie mccartney
truly again
very similar to candy burris someone
who's felt pinned down
a lot of heartbreak passed over for
certain opportunities
if you watched the masked singer for
just a single episode that the turtle
was on i defy you
to not hire jessie mccartney for your
next project sing
dances acts commands the stage a true
showman i could go on and on and on
and it was such a pleasure to be
reminded of his greatness throughout the
season what did you think
agreed with everything you just said i
think it was a very refreshing reminder
that jesse mccartney has
literally all of the talents and i think
the judges said it as well it's so great
to see him out here pushing himself and
trying new things and
even just doing things we haven't seen
him do in a while uh so
hats off to jesse mccartney the turtle
who really gave it his all this season
yeah and honestly i know it's not the
the top spot i do think
the night angel really deserved it after
that phenomenal performance
but second place still so incredible and
i think we'll remember him
in mass singer history forever for being
so iconic
and hopping right into the third spot
for season three
we have the frog take a look
[Applause]
there was a lot of strong vocalists here
so i knew i wasn't going out singer
outballing anybody so i said you know
what
i'm gonna come with the swag oh like
we've been guessing all season it's
bow wow again an unbelievable
entertainer a true
showman my humble two cents i would have
liked to have seen him take more risks
yeah i agree the week that he did that
imagine dragon song
where he kind of took on a more rocker
vibe
that's when everyone lost their marbles
and was like oh my god frog is for sure
gonna win because
i think the show is about showing that
you do different things with your voice
and you can cross
different genres and as much as i love
this diddy banger and as
amazing of a job as he did it just felt
very in his wheelhouse and
a true talent a tremendous talent i hope
this show catapults him into
making more music and doing more fun
things with his career but
i don't know i would have loved to have
seen a pop ballad or something like very
unexpected yeah i definitely agree i
think a ballad something we didn't
expect would have really launched him
into a better position in this final
three but he he was a great performer he
brought it every week on that stage with
dance something he says he's never done
before but clearly we saw him dance and
it was great
uh so i would love to see more of that
bow wow
his footwork was like usher status
exactly exactly and i do
have to take a moment deidre it's the
finale i think we need to look
back on this season and talk about our
favorite performances
what is the number one performance for
you
well if you've been watching unmasking
the math singer it's not a secret that i
am a seal stan so you can imagine the
level 10 meltdown i had
when the turtle during the opening week
of competition saying kiss from a rose
enjoy
[Applause]
well first of all that's iconic and
second of all
you know the next thing that i'm waiting
for right seal
the steel jesse mccartney hot fire
r b soulful duet that we all deserve
during quarantine we're manifesting it
put it in the universe
this is what we want two mass singer
legends collabing
give it to us okay what was your
favorite performance well speaking of
masking or legends i think it's only
right that i mentioned the queen
herself miss jojo siwa when she gave us
jai ho the most underrated pussycat
dolls bop
ever not to mention she sang it on the
stage with nicole after she was unmasked
take a look
[Applause]
another collab it's not a want it's a
need at this point
mass singer people uh jojo anyone if
you're watching
get me a cover of this song with these
two pop legends it's all i'm asking for
in all honesty i love that nicole
represents for
like my era when we were in high school
like the pussycat dolls and jojo siwa is
the new school version of girl power how
strong would it be to get them in a room
together
i would love to see it it's what we need
and by room i mean a recording studio
yes so it's
it's a bummer that season three of the
mass singer has come to an end but we
have
good news to look forward to fox has
announced season four
is happening charlie what can you tell
us well i can tell you that the ceo of
fox did release a statement saying that
despite the current covet 19 production
shutdown
should conditions allow it they are
planning to start production in early
august which would allow
season four to then air in the fall
which is obviously what we want
and as far as we know the judges and
nick cannon as the hosts are all
returning so it's our favorite mass
singer gang as usual
and i am just wondering what celebrities
are getting ready in quarantine
and possibly preparing to be on this
show
you know quarantine is a really good
exercise in anonymity
and avoiding others so hopefully they're
practicing
but i want to know is there anything
you'd want to see change
i will admit i do like the format from
season one
and two better than season three i don't
think i love the group a b
and c's as much because i felt like we
were seeing people for so many weeks and
then they disappear and then they come
back
i kind of like seeing them all and then
split up week by week if that makes
sense
totally i agree with that as well um i
would love to see this is also just
totally random i would love joel mchale
to join
the panel i love that he and ken
kind of always put each other in their
place and he's super
funny and very candid i think he'd be a
wonderful addition to the show
and i don't know we had 18 contestants
this season and sometimes i felt like it
was a lot of information to process
i'm happy with whatever they give us but
if they did go back to the original
like a number like 12 contestants i
wouldn't hate that either
i wouldn't hate that either and i agree
let's get joel up there permanently add
a fifth chair there's space for it on
that stage
we should be king him and hearing those
jokes every week and get excited
because the party is not officially over
check et online.com tomorrow because
we're gonna have interviews
with not only the winner the night angel
we're also talking with the frog bow wow
and the turtle jesse mccartney that is
right and of course guys thank you so
much for joining us i feel like deidre
and i have been going on the math singer
for
it feels like a year now non-stop and
thank you so much for watching
commenting
telling us what you think of the show we
appreciate all of it and of course while
you're in quarantine
you could re-watch past episodes or just
re-watch jai ho like i'm gonna
yes like charlie said just a huge thank
you to every single one of you who sent
us dms with your clues and your
thoughtful
investigations it's a weird time we
appreciate you sticking with us trying
to do the show
from the inside of our apartments and
we've had so much fun we hope you had
too and um
see you guys soon take care be safe we
love you
bye guys
[Music]